bonjour drieu godefridi merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
ce matin selon l'agrégateur de données
de sondage américain un regard clear
politics la dernière compilation de
projection qui date d'hier d'ailleurs
donne joe biden en tête 56 % pour
démocrate 43 1% pour donald trump
est-ce qu'il faut se fier à ces données
on se souvient qu'en 2016 les sondages
donnaient gagnante
hillary clinton donc en réalité à pour
la pour le motif que vous venez de dire
entre autres mais c'est un petit
accessoire il ne faut donner aucun
crédit à ces sondages
le motif principal est que la plupart de
ces sondages sont nationaux c'est à dire
ce sont des sondages qui porte sur une
élection qui n'a pas lieu parce que
l'élection américaine n'est pas
contrairement à l'élection
présidentielle française ne se calcule
pas sur l'ensemble de la population
elle se calcule par état et selon le
principe du collège électoral donc les
seuls sondages qui sont significatives
en tout cas davantage que le sondage
national sont les sondages par utah est
là quand on prend en compte ces sondages
encore faut-il tenir compte du fait que
un nombre important d'électeurs
républicains est donc favorable à
monsieur trump n'accepte pas de dire
qu'ils vont voter pour monsieur trump
quand une voix anonyme les appels pour
effectivement faire un sondage donc je
pense que si on regarde les indicateurs
objectifs
aujourd'hui ils pointent en rien un
kopeck trop catégorique vraiment un
prétendant à 1000 points que je dirai
davantage avait relu élections à de
monsieur trump que vers une élection de
ce bagage en quoi la présence de barack
obama peut-elle remobiliser les
électeurs démocrates
le prince et qu'il s'agit pas vraiment
de remobiliser les électeurs démocrates
icg mais plutôt de convaincre les
électeurs indépendants et éventuellement
une fraction des électeurs républicains
je pense que avec l'hercules beaucoup
d'américains considère aujourd'hui que
les deux mandats à de monsieur obama ont
été effroyable dans leurs résultats
qu'il s'agisse des résultats économiques
ou a fortiori des résultats sur le plan
juridique puisque on se souvient que la
négociation d'un suédois mats avait pris
avec le parti
de l'iran en concluant un accord assez
assez étonnant je dirais avec l'iran et
qu'il avait eu des effets
particulièrement des lecteurs dans le
monde
alors qu'ici nous avons une
administration américaine qui en a pris
le doigt l contre-pied en isolant l'iran
et en obtenant des accords de paix entre
israël et plusieurs états de la région
ce qui paraissait encore impensable il
ya quelques mois donc je ne suis pas
certain que le surgissement de monsieur
obama sur la scène électorale à c'est
d'ailleurs un conte gould parce que on
s'attendre à ce que ce soit le candidat
bagein qui passe campagne et par
l'ancien président je ne suis pas
certain que cela aura une influence
déterminante voire même aucune influence
sur sur le sort de l'élection et ce soir
on le sait il ya le troisième
l'ultime débat troisième il ya eu le
premier puis le deuxième on va dire
c'était à distance avec 2 int et radio
sur deux chaînes différentes
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre du débat
de ce soir avec des micro coupé quand
l'adversaire parlera donald trump et joe
biden ne pourront pas se couper la
parole
je crois qu'il le oui vous avez raison
c'est la règle donc que la commission a
deux cas à imaginer ici au dernier
moment je crois qu'il faut en attendre
ce qu'on a vu lors du premier débat est
en fait de tous les débats de la
campagne de 2007 c'était hier vous avez
un candidat républicain à trump pour ne
pas le nommer qui doit débattre avec son
opposant à démocrates mais également en
grande partie avec le présentateur
puisque nous avons des animateurs qui
sont des modérateurs comme comme on dit
parfois qu'ils sont dans leur écrasante
majorité démocrate voir des démocrates
fervent voir comme c'est le cas ce soit
une femme qu'on pourrait qualifier non
seulement de démocrates mais
passablement extrémistes donc vous aurez
ce soir cette nuit un débat entre le
candidat républicain
son opposant démocrates baden d'une part
mais en fait principalement et dans les
grosses vagues n est plus vraiment
beaucoup d'énergie intellectuelle et
d'énergie vitale
le soi-disant moderator qui complique
plus vraiment d'énergie intellectuelle
ou
vital c'est parce qu'il est chez lui
depuis dimanche c'est ça il dit qui se
prépare officiellement pour le débat de
ce soir est à linverse s'envoie donald
trump qui lui multiplie les phrases
virulentes à l'encontre de son de son
opposant on l'a vu encore cette nuit
avec avec ce meeting
ce sont deux attitudes complètement
complètement différente
comment les américains jugent ces
attitudes je pense que un signe
intéressant pour répondre à votre
question c'est le nombre d'américains
qui se déplacent pour assister au
meeting de monsieur tron quand monsieur
trump organise ya deux meetings l'un en
pensylvanie à l'autre en caroline du
nord
il a dit mines 20000 américain qui se
déplacent pour l'écouter donc
visiblement son public est très réceptif
à l'égard des fêtes qu'il fait campagne
ce qui est très surprenant de galles
fausse règle avec les indécis mais fait
qu'il ya du monde qui viennent comme ça
au meeting
je pense que ça traduit en tout cas un
enthousiasme qui est de nature à laisser
penser qu'un certain nombre d'électeurs
qu'on appelle indépendants aux états
unis vont se porter sur la candidature
de monsieur trump plutôt que sur la
candidature de monsieur bagel dernière
question de réglage freedy la commission
judiciaire du sénat vote tout à l'heure
sur l'approbation de la candidature de
la juge amicaux nibards est proposée par
donald trump pour la cour suprême
scrutin boycotté par les démocrates
en quoi la confirmation de sa nomination
peut-elle vraiment renforcé le camp
républicain
je pense que ça pourra d'une certaine
façon exacte et une fraction du temps
république en eux par la personne de
madame baroque et aussi par le fait que
c'est le troisième juge nommé par le
président trump à la cour suprême ce qui
comme le disait votre sujet juste avant
fera basculer durablement la cour
suprême dans le camp je dirais des
idéaux de liberté ou comme ça au titre
comme on dit à aux états unis merci à
drieu godefridi d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
l'auteur du livre la révolution 30 pause
édition texte qui